last week we set up an experiment to
test how good humans are at judging
volume by eye today we will see how our
viewers performed we did this because a
collection of spectacular elongated
skulls have been found in Peru
scientists tell us they are normal
humans with heads that were elongated
through skull binding I practice common
in many ancient cultures but guy.com
tells us that this cannot be the case
they claim that the skulls are not only
elongated but are 25% larger than normal
illustrations on their website suggests
that these skulls belong to
extraterrestrials is it possible that
Gaia calm is simply scamming us
exploiting humankind's poor ability at
judging volume by eye you are watching
episode 3 of citizen science versus the
aliens of Peru which one has 40
milliliters and one has 40 milliliters
exactly now Jackson you you did not see
which one has more which one has less I
want to get your guess before we do yeah
Jackson was watching my ear maker I set
this all up so he doesn't know which one
has less which one has more so what's
your guess which one which one has the
least amount of water in it colored
water you think the green one has less
all right which one has 40 milliliters
extra this one has less this one has
extra yep once test and find out we've
got our trusty beaker right here set
that aside so we don't spill it if it's
normal it should just read 400
what does that read that reads 400
number one was just regular if you
guessed that sorry you're wrong okay
number two what do you think it's gonna
be number two was less number two was 40
milliliters less 40 milliliters short of
400 look at that so if you guessed that
number 2 was less full you were correct
that links partially correct you still
have to get the other one as well
look at this it's nice beautiful green
mm-hmm
we're learning about colors too no no
we're gonna number 3 number 3 number 3
400 milliliters it's just regular normal
number 3 it was normal so number 2 had
less number 3 was normal number 1 is
normal
yeah it's fine 400 number 4 that was
number 4 and number 4 is normal all
right now we got number 5 what do you
think probably not number 5 Jackson I
happen to know
there's something special about this one
it is 440 milliliters number five was
the full one
if you guessed number two and four for
number two for less and live for five
more
you know one you got a right
congratulations so the rest of them this
one looks like it's really full but
let's just go ahead and mention the rest
too right
just so we can prove to the people some
might be suspicious 400 I like that just
a little food coloring in some water
probably good it's a food grade okay you
gotta be careful on to spill this on
this is tricky it's so close when you go
to a fancy restaurant and I did do these
weird shaped cups and so they can trick
you just 400 regular 400 400 milliliters
yeah it's just a trick 400 and last but
not least 400 it's a fun experiment it's
actually extremely extremely difficult
to get these right I am currently
recording this voice over Thursday night
at 9 p.m. the viewers have had a week to
turn in their ants
and before I can tell you if they played
well or not I need to calculate the odds
of getting this problem right by chance
if you dear audience happened to be a
bunch of monkeys choosing glasses at
random what would your odds be well
there are nine cups so getting the first
one right is a chance of one out of nine
and then because one of those has
already been chosen the odds of getting
the second one right assuming you got
the first one right are one in eight so
to find the chance of getting both
correct in a row we need to multiply the
fractions that's 1/9 times 1/8 is 1 in
72 it would take on average 72 monkeys
to play this game in order for one of
them to be statistically likely to get
it right to win well did my human
viewers do better than my hypothetical
monkeys nope not even close
89 people played and every single one of
them got it wrong in fact one person
miss Rousch n somehow managed to get it
perfectly wrong now don't worry this is
actually a really hard to do I could
really make a killing with this if I
turned it into a carnival game maybe I
should do that but I guess that
technically there was one guy that you
could say got outright YouTube user 2
laylax ooh face dancer he said I don't
know that was his answer and that you
know that that was technically correct
so congratulations to you sir now one of
the things I want to point out too is it
it's it's hard to do this when you're
here when you're in person it's even
harder to do it on the internet looking
through the TV or through your monitor
or through your phone at a video and
that is one of the reasons that these
alien conspiracy theory people have so
much success it's because people can't
actually see these with their eyes in
real life there's all sorts of
perspective games it's really hard to
tell how big something is when you're
looking at it on TV so but even even in
real life we have that problem as well
so that's it for this episode and next
week's episode Jackson and I are going
to talk about sagittal suture z' and
we're going to talk about the little
holes in the back
of the alien head and we're going to try
and figure out whether or not those
things are really that unusual for
humans because those were two of the
things that Brien Foerster says are
special about the elongated skull and
then after that we are going to do the
ultimate experiment we are going to
measure the skulls and see which one is
bigger than the other and so or if
they're the same size or if they're
really close to the same size that's
what we're going to see because the
claim is that this one is 25% larger
than this one and I suspect that that
might not be the case my suspicion so so
long for now stay curious
I ride here high five
[Music]
you